>> Laura: REALLY QUICK
ADDENDUM FROM THE PREVIOUS TOUR
WE JUST COVERED.
MY FRIEND GORDON, A FRESHMAN AT
UCONN JUST SAID I WASN'T ABLE TO
GET INTO THE SHAPIRO EVENT
EITHER.
EVERYONE WANTED TO GO.
MORE CONSERVATIVES ON CAMPUS
THAN PEOPLE THINK.
THANK YOU.
BY THE WAY, THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS ASKING TO SEE A
MEMO REPORTEDLY OUTLINING
SERIOUS WRONGDOING AT THE FBI
AND JUSTICE DEPARTMENT UNDER
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
HOUSE INTEL CHAIRMAN DEVIN NUNES
IS TAKING STEPS TO DECLASSIFY
THE MEMO SUMMARIZING THE
FINDINGS OF HIS RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION.
A LETTER FROM THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT CHARGES THAT IT WOULD
BE EXTRAORDINARY RECKLESS
TONIGHT TO RELEASE THE MEMO
WITHOUT FIRST GIVING THE DOJ AND
FBI AT THE TO REVIEW IT.
LET'S SORT THIS ALL OUT WITH
SOMEONE WHO HAS READ THE MEMO,
CONGRESSMAN PETER KING OF
NEW YORK.
I THOUGHT YOU WERE GOING TO BE
HERE WITH ME TONIGHT,
CONGRESSMAN WHO SERVES ON THE
INTEL COMMITTEE.
GREAT TO SEE YOU, HOW ARE YOU
DOING?
>> I'M DOING GREAT, LAURA, HOW
ARE YOU?
>> Laura: I'M GREAT.
WHAT DOES THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
AND THE FBI, THEY ARE SUDDENLY
ALL SQUARELY ABOUT THE RELEASE
OF THIS MEMO, WHAT GOES ON?
>> IT'S A FOUR-PAGE MEMO PUT
TOGETHER BY A VERY TALENTED
REPUBLICAN MEMBERS, MADE
AVAILABLE TO ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LAST WEEK TO BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO ALL THE MEMBERS OF
THE HOUSE.
IF THE FINDINGS VERY, VERY
SIGNIFICANT.
I BELIEVE TERRIBLE MISTAKES,
DELIBERATE WRONGDOING AT HIGH
LEVELS.
RIGHT NOW THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT -- WHAT DEVIN NUNES
PLANS ON DOING BECAUSE OVER 200
MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE LOOKED AT
IT, ONLY ABOUT TEN DEMOCRATS, BY
THE WAY.
THERE IS A CLIMBER BY THE PUBLIC
TO SEE THE MEMO.
WE WILL MAKE SURE THERE IS
NOTHING IN THERE -- THAT IS
PRETTY MUCH FINISHED.
IF THAT WILL BE DONE AND THEN WE
WILL VOTE THIS WEEK ON RELEASING
IT.
AT THAT STAGE IF WE GET A
MAJORITY VOTE, WHICH WE WILL, IT
WILL GO TO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
HE WILL DECIDE IF IT CAN BE MADE
TO THE PUBLIC.
THIS LETTER FOR THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
I HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR THE
FOR THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
BUT WE HAVE GOTTEN ALMOST NO
COOPERATION FROM THEM AT ALL
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS.
A LONG HARD FIGHT TO GET BASIC
DOCUMENTS THAT WE HAVE AN
ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO SEE.
WE GAVE THEM THIS MEMO, BUT THEY
WOULD DO, PASSED OUT ALL THE
THERE.
EVERYTHING THAT'S IN THAT MEMO
IS FROM THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
INFORMATION WE HAVE FOUND.
THERE'S NO SURPRISES THERE FOR
THEM, THEY JUST WANT TO BE READY
TO ATTACK IT AND THEY WANT TO
ATTACK IT.
MAKE A PREEMPTIVE ATTACK ON HIM.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO LET THEM.
I HAVE SPOKEN TO HIS STAFF
PEOPLE AND HE FULLY INTENDS TO
GO AHEAD.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO SHOW IT TO
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
>> Laura: KNOWING WHAT YOU
KNOW NOW, YOU HAVE READ THE
MEMO, YOU'VE SEEN THE EVIDENCE
SO FAR, DO YOU HAVE FAITH AS OF
NOW IN THE UPCOMING RESULTS OF
SEEN?
>> I'VE SAT THROUGH I DON'T KNOW
PROBABLY 20 WITNESSES WHO HAVE
COME BEFORE A COMMITTEE AND ALL
OF THE MAJOR ONES, I HAVE SAT
THERE FOR SEVEN, EIGHT, NINE
HOURS.
ALL THE BIG NAMES YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT.
I'VE BEEN THERE FOR THAT.
I HAVE NOT HEARD ONE WORD YET
INDICATING ANY COLLUSION.
I DON'T KNOW IF BOB MUELLER HAS
ANYTHING ELSE, BUT HE IS TALKING
TO MANY OF THE SAME PEOPLE.
IF THEY COME OUT WITH ANY
FINDING OF COLLUSION AT ALL
BASED ON WHAT I'VE HEARD, THEN I
WOULD SAY THEY ARE NOT DOING THE
JOB.
ON THE OTHER HAND, I THINK RIGHT
NOW I BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT'S
LAWYERS FEEL THIS GOING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION WITH ALL THE
IMPROPRIETIES THAT WENT ON, THE
FACT THAT THIS INVESTIGATION, I
BELIEVE, SHOULD NEVER HAVE BEEN
STARTED IN THE FIRST PLACE.
I LOOK UPON IT EITHER
INTENTIONALLY OR UNINTENTIONALLY
AS A HIT JOB.
THE FACTS ARE THAT YOU HAVE THE
INVESTIGATING A PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE BASED ON THE FLIMSIEST
OF EVIDENCE.
I WOULDN'T EVEN CALL IT
EVIDENCE.
AT THE FLIMSIEST RUMORS, THAT'S
WHAT THIS WAS BASED ON AND
THAT'S A TERRIBLE PRECEDENT TO
SET.
YOU COULD DO THAT TO ANY
CANDIDATE IF YOU WANTED TO.
WHEN YOU BRING THE FBI INTO A
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN, IT'S WRONG.
>> Laura: I WANT TO PLAY FOR
YOU A CLIFF I WATCHED THIS
AFTERNOON OF A FORMER RNC CHIEF,
MICHAEL STEELE.
HE WAS ON MSNBC AND HE WAS
CRITICIZING CONGRESS AND ANYONE
IN THE MEDIA WHO WOULD CAST
DISPERSIONS ON THE FBI HERE.
WHOLESALE OPERATION BETWEEN THE
WHITE HOUSE AND CAPITOL HILL TO
SULLY THE REPUTATION OF GOOD MEN
AND WOMEN WORKED INSIDE THE FBI
BECAUSE OF, AS YOU NOTED, SOME
EMAILS.
YES THEY ARE PROBLEMATIC, BUT
LET THE APPROPRIATE AUTHORITIES
FERRET THAT OUT.
TO DO WHAT THEY ARE DOING, THE
END GAME THEY ARE PLAYING RIGHT
NOW, WHAT THEY DON'T SEEM TO
UNDERSTAND, IT COULD BLOW UP IN
THEIR FACE JUST AS MUCH IS A
GOOD SULLY THE FBI.
>> Laura: RESPONSE,
CONGRESSMAN?
>> WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A
HANDFUL OF PEOPLE AT THE TOP.
IF THE FBI IS AN OUTSTANDING
ORGANIZATION.
PEOPLE AT THE TOP WHO HAVE NOT
SERVED THE FBI WELL.
I WOULD SAY THE RANK AND FILE OF
THE FBI, THEY ARE CONCERNED.
I'VE HEARD FROM RETIRED FBI
PEOPLE WHO ARE SHOCKED ABOUT
WHAT'S COMING OUT.
TO ME THE EMAILS AND TEXT
MESSAGES, THAT'S IMPORTANT.
THAT'S REALLY JUST AN INDICATION
OF THIS INVESTIGATION FROM THE
START.
STARTED.
IT'S BASED ON A FALSE PREMISE
AND ITS CONTINUING RIGHT THROUGH
WHETHER WE'RE TALKING WITH THE
FBI, CIA AND OTHERS.
THIS TO ME HAS ALL BEEN A
CONCERTED EFFORT TO GO AFTER
DISAGREE WITH DONALD TRUMP, BUT
TO SAY HE WAS COLLUDING WITH THE
I THINK IT'S SIGNIFICANT THAT
NOW IT'S BEING LEAKED TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
TALKING ABOUT OBSTRUCTION OF
DEAFNESS.
SIX MONTHS AFTER THE CAMPAIGN
WAS OVER.
>> Laura: EXECUTRIX.
WE NOTICED THE LEAKING RIGHT AS
THINGS STARTED TURNING REALLY